I saw a photo the other day you guys
yesterday you went to the set of the
mandalorian so let's talk about since
you know you can't spoil anything with
Avengers 4 let's talk about Star Wars
and so let's just talk so how did
everybody dive all right uh it's amazing
I mean think we went down there to say
hi to John Tyco was directing an episode
so one thing out with them and John is
always at the forefront of cutting-edge
attack and the ashiness in a way that no
one has ever shot anything ever before
pretty little sound you guys grow up
with Star Wars it's something that like
because you're a part of the part of the
Disney family now is that something
where you know you maybe have
conversations like is it something
you're interested in well we I mean we
grew up on Star Wars like everyone else
did I want to the various breaks back
and Santana Peter from 11:30 in the
morning till 10 o'clock at night and
watch it back back back back so it's it
was a huge influence on its growing up
of course you know love to work at some
point that was in it works but right now
our heads are